hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde wir machen heute eine tiktok
nicht lachen Challenge das heißt ich
werde gleich auf meine for you page
gehen mir Videos angucken und immer wenn
ich lachen muss bin ich ein kleiner
[ __ ] einfach nur sagen dass ich ein
richtig geisteskrank großes pomo Problem
hat und gestern feiern war bitte geh
es Wahrheit es gibt so was besseres
Paulaner Spezi irgendwie stream schauen
Nudeln bisschen chillen ich lasse jetzt
den Abend noch ausklingen ich war im
Schwimmbad das macht ihr so schönen
Abend euch noch ciao
ich habe dich dahinten spüren sehen ich
bin's kaum vor FC Bayern du hasst
Consulting Meeting I don't eat food I
can't just leave it there I want to
bring them some food but look what they
have
mant so this is the French nish company
chords mit seiner kleinen so eine
Legende
man kennt
[Musik]
ey es ist einfach alles wahr ne wie
viele Freundinnen hattest du bis jetzt
rein
oder durch Sonnenschein Loch also ja
Corona hat ziemlich viele
oh mein Gott
die in der Fahrschule in
Theorieunterricht mitgemacht haben
seid jetzt eigentlich bei der Formel 1
[Musik]
hey Bruder weißt du was geil wäre wenn
wir statt unser alter Level sagen zum
Beispiel ich bin Level 23 oder meine
Schwester bei Level viel gestorben Alter
Noob
[Musik]
t Mann
Mama ich habe bisschen Chat alle da
brauche Geist zu schauen Alter wie kann
ich dabei ernst bleiben mit wem möchten
Sie ein schönes Wochenende verbringen
mit ihrer Frau
[Musik]
hallo lieber Herr Frank Buschmann kommen
Sie mal aufhören
was denken
nicht aber nach treten
ja true Alter man wachte mal mitten in
der Nacht auf und man hat eine gefühlte
Wüste in seinem Mund
ah die Füße
da fast sagen dass ich in vollgeist
öfter Kontakt mit Obst hatte also
eine Banane berührt habe oder sowas
ohne Witz ganz im Ernst ich habe noch
nie in meinem Leben
geklautesine
ich habe gerade spontan herausgefunden
wenn du ein kleines bisschen
Zitronensäure auf deine Nasenspitze
machst
hast du im Alltag so einen kleinen
Zitrusduft so ein flavour alles Gute zum
Geburtstag
ihr wisst Ende der Bon your for you page
to you this a message
[Musik]
scare seid Ihr vielleicht sauer auf
jemanden habt ihr vielleicht negative
Emotionen heute dann ist das euer Moment
angry anymore ist mir alles egal
blickende sehr schön
ähm was
Jeffrey damals
[Musik]
ich habe diese Doku noch nicht geguckt
mit Jeffrey Dahmer ne
ist die nice weil ich nur gesehen die
ist bei Netflix ab 18 und da bin ich
dann immer so ein bisschen skeptisch
wie kann es sein dass solche kleinen
Kinder schon Fortnite zocken
auf einer Konsole
Bro mit elf Jahren habe ich mir meinen
Finger in den Arschloch gesteckt
Jeremy that
komm weiter
Bro
wir kriegen alle Schulverweis
Leute erwarte mal dass wenn sie sagen
hey Kellner dass sie dann direkt kommen
nee Bruder die haben vielleicht noch
zehn Bestellungen im Kopf die sich jetzt
mal merken müssen dann den Weg zur Küche
und zurück sind auch noch drei Zeitzone
müssen fünf Minuten noch und dann gibt
es Krautsalat
was ist das für
[Musik]
was ist das denn für ein kack Spiel
auf einmal
und ich habe Dinge gesehen die Menschen
nie zuvor gesehen hat
brennende Schiffe draußen vor der
Schulter des Orion vor dem Tannhäuser
Tor fragt bitte nicht was mit meiner for
you page kaputt ist
[Musik]
ey Bruder
vermisste shot mit meinem
count okay
vermisste schon
instagram
genau
[Musik]
was ist falsch mit die bei mir Pipi und
Kaki im Pipi Kaka Land ein Hörspiel von
Sabrina richard hat ein Schneider mit
einer Fliege Wrestling gemacht oder wie
gestritten weil er den Müll nicht
runterbringen wollte da war gestern beim
Friseur
dann hat er mir rote Rosen mitgebracht
aber ich mag halt eher die weißen Lust
jetzt hat
ich schwöre egal ob Frau oder Mann oder
keine Ahnung was wenn du in einer
Beziehung bist und du sagst deinen
Freunden dass du irgendein Problem was
alle sagen direkt mach Schluss sei
wieder Single weil die dann mehr Zeit
mit dem verbringen können ruf mal hinter
dir Rasen aus sag mal denkt ihr wirklich
dass es Greenscreen
was war das ey wie kann der Typ der
immer so laut reden vor allem
[Musik]
ich kann das alles nicht mehr was reimt
sich auf gestern hat in Österreich die
Erde gewebt
nein
du Christiane Ronaldo Russland
eingeklebt ja wir hätten uns eigentlich
auch
uns eigentlich auch bei diesem Wetter
auf die Terrasse setzen können
und für die die es nicht kapiert haben
das war ironisch gemeint ach so ah okay
danke wollte doch nur was bestimmtes
[Applaus]
[Musik]
warum funktioniert der verkaufsautomat
nicht weil wir uns in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern befinden nein
danke
warum
[Musik]
[Applaus]